[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravie de vous retrouver
dans Parlement hebdo pour cette nouvelle
saison 26 minutes pour revoir les temps
forts de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire sous le regard d'un invité
et pour commencer cette saison nous
accueillons à Yannick Jadot bonjour
bonjour vous avez été candidat à la
présidentielle et vous venez d'être élu
sénateur écologiste de Paris c'était
dimanche dernier aux élections
sénatoriales Yannick Jadot reviendra
bien sûr sur le nouveau visage du Sénat
après les élections du 24 septembre les
résultats en conforté la majorité
sénatoriale de droite et du centre la
gauche progresse le RN gagne trois
sièges
Elisabeth borne a donc déclenché
l'article 49-3 de la Constitution le 12e
de la législature pour faire passer le
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques qu'il avait été
rejeté l'an dernier
et puis y'aura-t-il une taxe super
profite pas si vite mais l'idée est en
tout cas remise sur la table à
l'occasion de l'examen du budget
et après les élections sénatoriales de
dimanche dernier le Sénat a donc été
renouvelé de moitié mais dans une
certaine stabilité plusieurs présidents
de groupe politique au Sénat ont été
réélus à leur poste cette semaine et
certains se démènent pour essayer
d'attirer dans leur rang les derniers
sénateurs indécis Reda am Rabbit
le Sénat version septembre 2023 mots
clés stabilité et quelques nouveautés
certes la droite conserve sa majorité
mais perd quelques sièges la faute à des
dissidences pour le reste on prend les
mêmes et on recommence Bruno Retailleau
et réélu pour la quatrième fois
président du groupe les républicains et
pour moi c'est un honneur d'être désigné
mais pour le Sénat c'est fondamental
imaginez que le groupe majoritaire
principal
soit des Unis il y aurait plus de code
vertébrale et alors là le Sénat
s'effondre présidence de groupe conservé
pour Hervé Marseille mais le problème
est ailleurs pour le sénateur des
Hauts-de-Seine qui espèrent avoir de
nouveaux membres au sein du groupe Union
centriste et ben on va en gagner
des mystères
d'ici la semaine prochaine voilà vous
devez le savoir non parce qu'il y a des
gens qui sont encore hésitants à l'heure
actuelle vous en avez combien vous avez
fait votre première réunion à l'heure
actuelle combien
développement on est normalement à 56 57
là dans cette mission Hervé Marseille
doit faire face à François Patriat qui
espère grossir les rangs du groupe RDPI
et Claude maguret pour les indépendants
autre bataille au sein du groupe
socialiste sur fond de division lié au
parti un match qui opposait Patrick
canner le sortant à Éric kerouche
Candida soutenu par Olivier fort c'est
finalement le sénateur du Nord qui l'a
emporté avec 38 voix contre 25 je crois
que le score est quand même très net en
ma faveur mais je ne m'en fais pas un
élément de gloriole moi mon premier
message c'est le dire et ça a été de
dire tu as présenté un programme j'ai
présenté un programme regardons ce qui
est compatible c'est qu'il va
fonctionner ensemble et nous porterons
cette feuille de route non pas au nom de
Patrick kaner ou non d'Héric et rouge
mais au nom d'un groupe socialiste
rassemblé
côté écologiste si Guillaume Gontard
conserve la présidence du groupe
l'attraction est ailleurs avec Mathilde
Olivier un des nouveaux visages du Sénat
benjamine de remicycle autre nouveauté
le retour du rassemblement national avec
trois sénateurs qui font rentrer au
Palais du Luxembourg un palais dont le
maître des lieux devrait être Gérard
Larcher sa réélection probable est
prévue pour le 2 octobre prochain
Yannick Jadot question toute simple pour
commencer pourquoi avoir choisi le Sénat
parce que notre pays ne va pas bien
je considère que notre pays est tétanisé
il fait du surplace aujourd'hui que
il n'arrive plus à se projeter dans un
avenir qu'il juge angoissant avec un
présent très inquiétant donc on voit
toutes les pensées politiques
rétrogrades conservatrices y compris
d'extrême droite
mythifier un passé et donc moi je veux
participer au Sénat sur le champ de la
politique nationale à remettre notre
pays en mouvement à faire que l'agenda
écologique ne soit pas un agenda
où on fait semblance qui a été la le
discours de planification écologique du
président de la République beaucoup
beaucoup de plus en plus d'injustices
sociales un affaissement démocratique
qui va nous conduire à l'élection de
Marine Le Pen avec un premier ministre
LR on voit bien sa dérive en 2027 donc
je me résigne pas ça je veux
dans le cadre des lois aussi à faire en
sorte à faire en sorte que les porter au
Sénat quels engagements
vous savez que
l'environnement est une compétence
européenne tout notre droit de
l'environnement en France est construit
en Europe on voit à quel point il est
pas toujours satisfaisant mais la France
est condamnée ou mise en demeure pour
non application du droit européen sur la
pollution de l'air sur le climat sur les
espèces protégées sur la protection de
nos eaux donc moi je veux que la France
soit à la hauteur du défi
environnemental et puis il y a des
enjeux d'urgence on voit bien que il y a
une épuration ethnique dans le
haut-karaba on voit à quel point
l'Azerbaïdjan aujourd'hui est laissé
libre de ce que les Nations Unies
considèrent la mise en place d'un
génocide des Nations Unies considèrent
qu'il y a 4 des 5 critères justement que
fait l'Union européenne que fait
l'Europe
pensait que fait la France passait
pourtant la France historiquement y
compris à travers de manière très trans
partisane est aux côtés des Arméniens
mais là on voit que le fait que
l'Azerbaïdjan produit et nous exporte en
Europe du gaz fait que nous laissons ce
pays sans sanction et il va falloir que
le le Sénat comme les autres
institutions françaises européennes s'en
en parle qu'on est un véritablement un
régime de sanctions très lourd contre
l'Azerbaïdjan et qu'on arrête de
considérer que les Arméniens sont le
prix à payer de de notre addiction au
gaz il y a quelques jours encore le
président de Total
le PDG de Total Patrick pouyanet était
avec le président allief alors que
s'organiser l'épuration ethnique des
Arméniens décidément on a un grand
groupe français historique qui est après
avoir été aux côtés de Poutine et aux
côtés aujourd'hui d'allieve toujours du
côté des génocidaires jamais des
victimes alors revenons sur votre
arrivée au Sénat à certains disent que
votre nouveau mandat de sénateur à Paris
ce serait un tremplin pour la mairie de
Paris en 2026 qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez écoutez que vous savez
l'élection sénatoriale c'est fait pour
élire des sénatrices et des sénateurs je
veux dire c'est compliqué l'élection
sénatoriale le mode de scrutin les
Françaises et les Français passent à
côté c'est normal voilà ce sont des
grands électeurs ce sont les élus dans
les collectivités locales mais il y a
pas de secret le scrutin sénatorial
s'est fait c'est fait pour élire des
sénateurs des sénatrices et je suis très
content d'arriver au Sénat dans cette
maison qui a pris vous le savez
encore plus de place dans notre
démocratie sous la présidence d'Emmanuel
Macron
[Musique]
ce jeudi de cette semaine c'était la
journée internationale pour le droit
l'environnement un enjeu absolument
essentiel et c'est par exemple les
écologistes qui en commençant par le
Sénat ont porté la
constitutionnalisation du droit l'IVG
donc vous voyez que c'est une
institution qui qui mérite notre
attention et nos combats une institution
il y a beaucoup de stabilité lundi
l'élection du président du Sénat a lieu
Gérard de très fortes chances d'être
réélis n'est pas de votre bord politique
et mais est-ce que vous lui reconnaissez
aussi quelques qualités politiques
écoutez moi j'arrive au Sénat donc j'ai
pas attiré un bilan de la présidence de
Gérard Larcher mais incontestablement il
a acquis le respect de tous les groupes
politiques malgré les différences
parfois les divergences politiques on le
verra aussi sur le projet de loi sur
l'immigration qui va arriver très
rapidement
mais incontestablement il est respecté
par les groupes politiques parce qu'il
les respecte ce qui est de bonne augure
parlons de la gauche sénatoriale qui
sort renforcée de ces élections tout
groupe politique confondu à gauche et
bien le seuil pourrait atteindre les 100
sénateurs quel doit être la ligne
politique de cette gauche et notoriale
est-ce que ça doit être la même ligne
que la gauche nups à l'Assemblée
nationale qui rassemblée autour de la
France insoumise non
non parce que vous l'avez dit le Sénat
ne fonctionne pas comme l'Assemblée
nationale
le Sénat est une institution malgré le
fait qu'il y a un groupe majoritaire
plutôt très conservateur c'est un groupe
qui fonctionne aussi c'est un assemblée
qui fonctionne aussi sur le compromis
un peu je dirais à distance de
l'agitation médiatique et
le Sénat est moins porté sur le buzz sur
l'invective et peut-être davantage porté
sur le travail de fond ce n'est pas
remettre en cause le travail que font
mes collègues écologistes à l'Assemblée
ils ont encore proposé des mesures très
concrètes sur la planification
écologique sur le budget le projet de
budget qui arrive sur l'ensemble des
sujets mais la perception qu'on les
Françaises et des Français de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est parfois le
bazar
c'est pas la perception qu'ils ont du
Sénat ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas des
tensions ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas
de la controverse mais il y a c'est
moins sujet à la polémique et puis vous
l'avez dit ils sont pas les mêmes forces
politiques qui sont au Sénat ça raconte
aussi les ancrages locaux des
différentes forces politiques moi je
suis très content que le groupe
écologiste se renforce au Sénat on verra
combien on sera lundi puisque c'est
l'indique on formalisera les groupes
politiques mais regardez à Paris on est
passé à deux sénatrices un sénateurs ça
dit aussi la progression des écologistes
sur nos territoires justement il y a un
premier grand texte qui arrive à au
Sénat ce sera la la loi immigration que
prépare en ce moment Gérard dahmanin un
texte que prévoit dans notamment la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers dit en tension
est-ce que c'est pas très clair on
reconnaitre
une telle mesure on parle bien de cette
mesure là on parle de cette mesure-là
vous voyez bien que on est dans une
difficulté
on est aujourd'hui sur un débat sur les
migrations qui est absolument dramatique
on a l'impression ça pourrait être le
débat est-ce que la terre est plate vous
avez un certain nombre d'arguments qui
sont avancés par ce gouvernement la
droite et l'extrême droite qui n'ont
rien à voir rien à voir avec la réalité
et je pense que c'est de notre
responsabilité collective je veux dire
quelqu'un viendrait ici sur le plateau
en disant écoutez désolé mais j'ai
vérifié la terre est plate vous verriez
mais ce type il est cinglé
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand on parle
d'appel d'air par exemple quand on dit
régulariser les sans-papiers les
travailleurs sans papier
il y a pas une étude française
européenne internationale qui démontre
que régulariser c'est faire un appel
d'air deuxième contre vérité mensonge
agité par l'extrême droite et reprise
malheureusement par le Président de la
République dans son intervention sur sur
TF1 il dit au fond nous avons un système
social très généreux sous-entendu
les immigrés viennent pour notre système
social deuxièmement ils sont notre
système social paye pour l'immigration
toutes les études montrent que les
immigrés contribuent positivement à nos
finances publiques à notre système
social troisième contre vérité mensonge
du président râpé j'arrive parce que
c'était essentiel parce que si on remet
pas le débat comme il veut il dit au
fond la France fait sa part plus que ça
part nous sommes les meilleurs du monde
ce qui est le président de la République
on est toujours la meilleure du monde
mais plus que ça part sur l'accueil des
réfugiés c'est faux même sur les
Ukrainiens on fait beaucoup moins que
nos voisins le donc tout ça pour dire
quoi un il faut régulariser les
travailleurs sans papiers absolument
s'il y a une mesure qui va vers la
régularisation
responsable des travailleurs sans
papiers et pas leur précarisation oui
nous irons vers cette mesure mais tout
le reste tout le reste tout le reste
c'est de la manipulation du mensonge des
contre vérités qui veulent faire des
étrangers les boucs émissaires de nos
crises
6 mois après la réforme des retraites
Elisabeth borne a déclenché un nouveau
49-3 c'était ce mercredi à l'Assemblée
nationale juste avant minuit le texte
avait été rejeté il y a un an retour en
séance avec Maïté Frémont nous avons
besoin la fin de cette loi de
programmation de nos finances publiques
nous ne pouvons pas prendre le moindre
risque les débats auront duré moins de
trois heures quand Elisabeth borne
brandit pour la première fois de cette
session parlementaire
de
ses opposants le 49 j'engage la
responsabilité finances publiques je
vous remercie
ils sont dans un déni démocratique nous
n'en changeons pas la réponse est
commune elle est unie laupes portera une
motion de censure ensemble pour répondre
au Gouvernement la carte du 49.3
utilisée foot de majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée car l'opposition de droite
comme de gauche l'avait annoncée pas
question de soutenir cette loi de
programmation des finances publiques
autrement dit la trajectoire budgétaire
de la France jusqu'en 2027 cette oriente
budget orientation budgétaire est la
pire que qui est jamais été faite dans
notre pays puisque on parle de 70
milliards d'économies sur le dos des
Français et des Françaises ici à 2027
prévient les Français depuis 15 mois on
dit que toutes ces postures de Madame
borne ne sont que de la comédie en fait
ils sont incapables d'accepter la
moindre modification le rassemble
national avait d'abord obtenu puis après
ça s'est perdu dans les couloirs de
Bercy et un ajustement pour ne pas taxer
injustement les agriculteurs le secteur
du logement
le transport de marchandises et même ça
ils sont incapables de discuter la
majorité fustige les réactions des
oppositions même quand l'intérêt général
de notre pays est en jeu même quand on
parle de 18 milliards de ressources de
la part de l'Europe même quand on parle
d'une trajectoire de maîtrise de nos
finances publiques et bien les
oppositions ne sont pas capables d'être
raisonnables d'être responsable au total
depuis son arrivée à Matignon et
d'isabeth borne aura eu recours 12 fois
à l'article 49.3 une dizaine d’autres
seraient prévu à l'automne sur les
budgets de l'État et de la sécurité
sociale
Elisabeth borne a donc utilisé de
nouveau le 49-3 sans doute le premier
d'une longue série mais pourtant c'est
sans surprise les oppositions avaient
dit qu'elles ne voterait pas le texte
c'était normal que le gouvernement
utilise le 49-3 non ce qui est pas
normal c'est qu'il est pas une
discussion à l'Assemblée plus riche sur
les grands enjeux d'un budget vous
souvenez il y a un an l'Assemblée
nationale par exemple voter
majoritairement pour qu'on ait un budget
à la hauteur du défi de la rénovation
thermique de nos logements le Parlement
l'assemblée votait 10 milliards de plus
dans le budget parce qu'on sait que ce
sont des millions et des millions de
familles françaises qui vont avoir froid
cet hiver qui ont étouffé cet été on a
besoin de rénover y compris on parlait
tout à l'heure du du des Azerbaïdjan a
besoin de s'affranchir de nos
dépendances en énergie fossile on a
besoin d'aider les Français dans leur
pouvoir d'achat donc
une discussion au fond sur un certain
nombre de priorités qui sont mises en
avant par le Président de la République
mais qui se retrouvent pas dans le
budget je trouve ça dommage le 49-3
aujourd'hui est un constat au fond du
dysfonctionnement de l'Assemblée
nationale il a été mis sur un texte que
dont la France dit qu'il est obligatoire
pour avoir le versement des fonds
européens est-ce que c'est vrai ou faux
alors dites-nous parce que vous vous
connaissez toutes les Archanges
tout le monde s'est affranchi des règles
budgétaires qui ne font plus aucun sens
d'ailleurs le débat européen aujourd'hui
sur ce qu'on appelle les critères de
Maastricht c'est-à-dire à la fois le
déficit du budget et le montant de la
dette ce débat il est à l'agenda des
institutions européennes pour
transformer ces critères la question
c'est pas de laisser filer la dette et
de dépenser n'importe comment le min le
maire à en rigolant accepter de
reconnaître qu'on avait cramé 12
milliards de protection sur l'énergie
pour les plus riches dans notre pays et
qu'on aurait pu s'affranchir de cette
dépense donc bien sûr qu'il faut mieux
dépenser l'argent qu'il faut
conditionner les aides aux entreprises
conditionner les exonérations sur les
cotisations sociales faire en sorte mais
investir aujourd'hui sur la question
climatique ça n'est pas une dette c'est
un investissement qui nous permettra de
mieux vivre donc le
l'instrumentalisation de l'Europe
aujourd'hui elle est totalement mal
placée de la part de ce gouvernement
alors justement dans le budget 2024 qui
a été présenté cette semaine par le
gouvernement et qui sera débattu par les
parlementaires pendant tout l'automne et
bien il y a 16 milliards d'euros
d'économies mais il y a aussi des
dépenses qui augmentent sur certains
postes notamment la transition
écologique avec 7 milliards d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires pour financer
le bonus à l'achat des véhicules
électriques pour les ménages modestes
financer les primoréation thermique ou
encore le nouveau crédit d'impôt
industrie verte le gouvernement parle de
budget vert vous êtes d'accord non non
malheureusement vous savez moi ce que
j'attendais du discours du président de
la République sur la planification
écologique c'était pas ni cure ni déni
une sorte de de retrait permanent ou le
président de la République nous
expliquait que malgré l'urgence
climatique absolue on entre seulement
dans un cycle de chaos climatique ça
veut dire que c'est ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui ça va être de plus en plus
dur et ce qui nous dit
non c'est pas suffisant mais ce qui nous
dit le président de la République c'est
qu'il y aura du nucléaire en 2050 il y
aura un avion vert en 2050 il y aura on
va faire des SUV électrique partout pour
remplacer les voitures thermiques mais
qui peut se payer un SUV électrique qui
peut se payer aujourd'hui une voiture à
60 000 euros parce qu'on a laissé à la
fois les altern ici vos voitures un peu
en déshérence les transports collectifs
renforcer le forfait mobilité dans les
entreprises leur rendent obligatoire
pour favoriser le covoiturage favoriser
la mobilité douce on n'a pas imposé aux
industriels de l'automobile le fait de
faire des petits véhicules électriques
accessibles donc on laisse les
constructeurs faire des bagnoles à 60
000 euros et c'est l'argent public qui
doit aider le leasing peut être une
bonne idée le chèque énergie n'est pas
suffisant mais quand on aide il faut
aider les plus vulnérables les grands
vainqueurs de la transition écologique
ça doit être les plus vulnérables sur
les transports sur l'alimentation sur le
logement sur tous ces sujets là donc
malheureusement ça n'est pas un budget
vert et on a un président de la
République qui joue avec le dérèglement
climatique qui fait semblant qui fait
comme si on attendait la mobilisation
générale il a souvent déclaré la guerre
il aurait dû déclarer la guerre au
dérèglement climatique malheureusement
il s'ingénue à passer des armistices
avec les grands lobbys qui nous
contraignent dans ce modèle déprimant
alors dans ce budget 2024 au Parlement
est l'idée d'une taxe sur les super
profits va être remise sur la table par
certains parlementaires notamment par
les sénateurs centristes on va écouter
sur ce point le président du groupe de
l'Union centriste au Sénat Hervé
Marseille j'entends une petite musique
on y revient c'est que plutôt que de
demander poliment au patron de Total ou
de tel autre distributeur s'il vous
plaît monsieur à votre bon cœur est-ce
qu'on peut faire un geste c'est que
l'État soit moi je suis républicain
c'est régulateur c'est à dire que on
taxe les profits
insensés et exceptionnel que font
certaines grandes entreprises et des
tarot distribue c'est ça le rôle de
l'État plutôt que de bidouiller avec des
opérateurs et s'il te plaît est-ce que
tu peux faire l'essence moins cher donc
Yannick Jadot est-ce que la gauche
sénatoriale pourrait s'entendre avec les
sénateurs centrices pour voter cette
taxe sur les super profits au Sénat mais
bien sûr comme on a cherché à s'entendre
à l'Assemblée nationale on parlait du
précédent budget il y avait une majorité
à l'Assemblée nationale pour porter
parce que le gouvernement s'y oppose
quand je dis que le Président de la
République ils sont gouvernement passe
leur temps à servir les lobbys du
pétrole de la bagnole des pesticides
et on pourrait les ajouter chasseurs
enfin pour les ajouter les uns aux
autres et enfin prenez une entreprise
totale
20 milliards de profits les trois quarts
redistribués aux actionnaires et on se
satisfait que Total dépense quelques
dizaines de millions pour
stabiliser la hausse du prix de
l'essence en faisant y compris en
faisant une grosse opération commerciale
c'est pas possible que des entreprises
au fond ce goinfre pour les actionnaires
pour leur profit sur les automobilistes
sur les consommateurs sur les habitants
dans leur logement
participent de l'écrasement des
Ukrainiens ou des Arméniens on a on en a
et que il n'est même pas à contribuer à
les formes nationales tout ça est devenu
totalement aberrant il faut remettre
vous savez des gens deviennent dingues
deviennent dingues en voyant les
milliards valser dans certaines
entreprises et se faire taper parce
qu'on est RSA se faire taper parce qu'on
est chômeur se faire taper parce qu'on
est travailleur
se faire taper parce qu'on est mal logé
qu'on n'arrive plus à payer son logement
il supporte plus justement cet axe c'est
votre combat c'est aussi celui de
d'Hervé est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
peut y avoir un accord du Parlement
Parlement donc Assemblée nationale Senna
qui décide de façon possible
qu'on peut obtenir une majorité après
vous pouvez pas imposer ça au
gouvernement parce qu'à un moment donné
il dit moi la justice sociale je suis
contre agir pour le climat je suis
contre et même avec une majorité
pourtant on a une droite dont on peut
pas dire qu'elle soit très juste
socialement et aujourd'hui très engagé
sur l'écologie mais vous avez quand même
un certain nombre de parlementaires qui
même les centrises vous voyez bien ils
disent mais c'est totalement aberrant de
voir des groupes sur les transports
maritimes sur l'énergie sur
l'agroalimentaire se remplir aujourd'hui
se gaver sur les consommateurs et sur
les citoyens et ne pas contribuer à
mettre un peu de justice social dans ce
pays donc on peut obtenir une majorité
encore faut-il que ce gouvernement puis
et la volonté de d'accepter de taxer
ceux qui aujourd'hui sont des profiteurs
de crise est-ce que vous croyez encore à
la proposition d'un ISF vers un impôt
sur la fortune climatique il faut la
remettre sur la table cette mesure il
faudra toujours la remettre sur la table
vous pouvez pas vous savez combien les
ultras riches puisqu'on parle quand on
parle des sèves on est quand même sur
les ultra-riches sont beaucoup plus
pollueurs beaucoup plus émetteurs de gaz
à effet de serre que la moyenne des
Françaises et des Français à travers
notamment leur patrimoine leur placement
financier et donc il faut à la fois
l'ISF l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune qui n'a jamais servi le
ruissellement tel que promis par le
Président de la République
remettre un ISF et puis avoir un ISF moi
j'avais porté pendant la campagne
présidentielle un problématique donc
avec une taxation supplémentaire sur les
placements sur les patrimoines ou avoir
un type d'isfaire tels que les avait
proposé ma fuz et Pisani ferries
c'est-à-dire un impôt exceptionnel sur
les Ultra riches encore une fois là
c'est la base de notre action sur
l'écologie la justice sociale ce sera le
mot de la fin merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité pour ce premier numéro de
Parlement Hebdo de la saison et merci à
tous de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour ne rien rater des
incontournables du Parlement tchao
[Musique]